what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
alright so picking up with the return of
antivenom where I guess really you know
the amazing spider-man is really what
we're doing again this is all part of
dance slots run this is the cool thing
is because Dan Slott again you know
usually the early aspects of his run to
clean out a lot of the stuff you didn't
really care for with regards to this
whole committee ran amazing spider-man
series and so because of that you know
the the return of antivenom is designed
to really just deal with Martin Lee now
again we talked to you know before about
how Martin Lee was one side at the same
point yeah you had the Martin Lee
personality and you had the mr. negative
personality mr. negative knew about
Martin leave but Martin Lee didn't know
about mr. negative of course Martin Lee
being a legitimate guy a guy to
basically ran a charity center but mr.
negative was this you know mr. Hyde
persona kind of thing where he basically
used the chair just a charity center as
a front for drug running money
laundering all these criminal schemes
that he could basically run out of New
York now this also deals a lot with
anti-venom in a sense that Eddie Brock
is looking to basically eliminate Martin
Lee because you get sitters Martin Lee
to be a cancer on the society itself now
a lot of this religious or at least that
the lead story initially picks up is the
whole idea that anti-venom just kind of
busts in in the middle of a of a drug
bust or I'm sorry I have a drug deal by
Martin Lee's guys and starts to take
them all out the problem is that partway
through this
we're actually met by the arrival of the
race so this is kind of a weird
situation here because the rate was a
character that predates Dan Slott you
know really like one more day predates
that by maybe 20 years or something like
that the rates that you know brian de
wolf originally appeared in like 1985 i
want to say was Peter Parker the
spectacular spider-man or something like
that
he appeared quite some time ago he was a
Salva Simha
creation and maybe a bill Mantlo
creation but basically he was just kind
of one of these these aspects of
bolstering the spider-man mythos adding
new characters in he was a vigilante
with psionic powers there's a whole
weird origin story that goes into him
but he was kinda like this on again off
again a lie the same time the brian de
wolf persona that we knew was basically
killed off and the Punisher and so the
idea here is
one in the heck is going on who is this
version of the race which is kind of
crazy now of course Dan Slott teases us
a little bit then one of the people
asked like who are you know one of these
guys who are you what are you doing here
and this person says well I'll reveal my
identity but we never find out what it
is instead we just kind of switch over
to two antivenom as he takes out the
last of these guys finally tracks down
where does the race is gone only to
discover that this is Jean dewolff now
this being Jean dewolff should
technically be impossible because Jean
dewolff is dead like she was she was
shot of course she was the sister of
Brian de Wolfe the original race she was
a detective that worked alongside Peter
Parker spider-man for quite some time
she was an ally to a lot of the
superhero community she was almost like
this misty Knight s character except
where misty Knight was kind of like an
information broker or you know
street-level heroes and so on and so
forth Jean dewolff kind of operated by
passing information from within the
police precinct itself to keep
superheroes on the up enough to let them
always know what the police are doing
what they're trying to track down so
that superheroes could go track down
these crimes you know and deal with
people if they didn't think the police
could pull it off on their own the
problem is that regime that was being
dead and most everybody knowing that
she's dead the question is who is this
chick who is this girl not from here
again we jump back to to Peter Parker
this is always kind of a cool thing
because again you know dancefloor tells
us hey look Carly Cooper does not know
that Peter Parker is spider-man she has
no idea about this stuff she's just like
yeah Peter Parker like congratulations
on your big day now we don't know what
the big day is something big is
apparently happening at Horizon labs and
it's kind of cool because dance launch
stories with this Peter Parker goes and
meets with with max Modell you know he
shows Maximo Dell and experiment or I
guess an object he's been working on a
helmet that can withstand virtually any
kind of collision without damage to it
it's just like a lot of these things
that are sort of going on with his own
individual character but then we find
out that the big day is that Peter
Parker was published an American science
journal and what it does is it gives a
lot of legitimacy to Peter Parker he's
like yeah hit it big time like it's
really funny because it's like Peter
Parker's getting all the things that he
hoped for that instead of just being
this kid who's selling photographs for
the Daily Bugle playing at day by day
trying to be a superhero being broke all
the time trying to balance the oh
romance and so on and so forth that he's
actually hitting a big time he's
actually achieving all the goals that he
set out to achieve now the funny thing
here too is that he talks to Aunt May
and Aunt May is like oh you're an
American science journal is like well
that's um
it's like this it's like the grandmas
response to being you know to you being
happy about something that they don't
understand but again we find out that
she understands perfectly that she
actually printed off a ton of copies or
ordered a ton of copies and she's been
handing it out to everybody in the feast
shelter she's like yeah like my nephew
was an American science journal like I
said it's so cool and it's so exciting
but of course again because of the fact
that antivenom knows that the whole
Martin Lee mr- persona is operating out
of the fee shelter because he's using it
as a way to basically run drugs to
engage in human trafficking different
things like that he's basically
operating in this location albeit in a
disguise in order to figure out what's
going on to make a move here now of
course with regards to Martin Lee being
guarded by his inner demons Martin Lee
actually goes to visit or at least goes
out to shake the hand of Aunt May to
thank her for all of her work but then
this little to get a really cool
situation
somewhere along the line Aunt May had
witnessed Martin Lee killing one of his
henchmen and her reaction was oh my god
I've got to tell somebody about this
but then Martin Lee had basically
touched her in wiped her mind so that
she didn't recall the incident now of
course this causes aunt made to pass out
and what this does is this was a bit of
a panic in the situation but I mean it
puts kind of a kick in the wheel because
now Peter Parker's responding to you
know the whole incident with Aunt May
while at the same time trying to be a
superhero and that's really that's
really how things go when it comes to
the character with every you know single
spider-man story I wouldn't go as far as
to say this like oh I may have been
injured again you know we gotta you got
to get around for the hospital and Peter
Parker's got a response it's not always
that situation but with every spider-man
story there's always a scenario that's
injected we're kind of put the bit of
panic into the situation like will Peter
Parker make it there in time that's one
of the reasons why a lot of fans still
love spider-man stories so much or at
least loved in the early days when that
dance class started writing it is
because it maintained a lot of the older
themes of spider-man you know from the
era when his character was so popular
and remained so popular because it was
this idea that is like will spider-man
get there in time you know what this
whole situation but during this it's
also dance loss showing us again where
Eddie rock stands that's a cool thing
you know whether it was Zeb well who was
writing you know the whole anti venom
Punisher team-up whether it is Dan Slott
when he originally introduced anti-venom
to the spider-man mythos it was Eddie
Brock trying to be a good guy and what
he does is he kind of chastising himself
for not acting sooner he's like I should
have done something sooner I should have
acted sooner otherwise
never have been endangered that's kind
of a kicker here is because would on may
being as old as she is this could result
in her dying like this could this could
result in her death because she's old
she's fragile
you know she's almost done with all her
living as it is something like this
could result in her being killed and so
of course the antivenom kind of jumps
into the whole situation right you know
and again this is Dan Slott saying hey
guys let's let's just kind of engineer a
situation where spider-man and
anti-venom fight one another because
again spider-man and anti-venom teaming
up to a degree was only situational in
the sense that it was spider-man not
really knowing what anti-venom was about
just knowing that Eddie Brock was
claiming to try to be a good guy but in
this moment when spider-man arrives on
the scene and anti-venom it's carrying
over the roof of a car with Martin Lee
inside
spider-man's reaction is Martin leads a
good guy Martin Lee is the head of the
of the feast shelter that has got a
criminal that guy's a legitimate dude
and so in his mind Eddie Brock's
reverted back to being a criminal again
pencil of course this just kind of
dissolves down into a fight between the
two and they just you know they just
sort of start going at it it's actually
kind of cool to see them you know going
against one another because remember
with anti-venom whenever he's in the
vicinity of Peter Parker he sends his
powers all into the cattywampus so they
just kind of start going crazy and so
because of that Peter starts losing a
lot of his ability it's being unable to
tap into them being unable to be as
efficient as he normally is and it's
just a way for Dan Slott to basically
introduce anti-venom in a fashion that
gives them kind of an upper hand on on
Peter Parker and that's why it's cool is
because Eddie venom keep saying the
entire time like I'm trying to be a good
guy and trying to be a good guy just
listen stop fighting me and just listen
you know and so finally he gets the
upper hand on Peter Parker right I mean
Martin Lee makes his escape you know his
guys get away finally he gets his hands
on Peter Parker and he basically takes
them captive the problem is that Eddie
Brock takes into what used to be a meth
lab and it's kind of messed up because
Peter Parker's I do too smells funny in
here he's like well the people that ran
this before they were running a meth lab
and I ran them all out but I'm putting
you here now to despicably keep you out
of the way you know of course again
because of the fact that antivenoms
webbing is filled with the antibodies
that his body houses in order to give
him his powers spider-man can't just
break out you know you can't just escape
by normal means so the cool thing about
this Letty brought talks to mrs. McMahon
more than we is mr. negative like you
know who mr. negative is you've never
been able to catch him but you know who
mr. negative is he's this warlord of
Chinatown you know this running all
these these drugs and people and money
laundering all
kind of stuff the reason why you've
never caught him is because he's Martin
Lee because when you're a you seat of a
million times you just didn't know it
was him now of course Peter Parker's
responses well this is ridiculous
there's no way that that's the case but
the other thing to remember here is that
Peter Parker doesn't have a spider sense
remember he lost that and so it wasn't
like he you know came across mr. Lee and
his spider sense activated he didn't
have any way to know he just kind of has
to take Eddie Brock at his word and
that's why Peter losing his spider sense
it's kind of cool here you know because
it turned down that he did have its
rider since any came across Martin Lee
it would almost immediately kicked off
because number Martin Lee and this part
of the story is mr. negative just posing
as Martin Lee and so he's still a bad
guy and Peter Parker Spyder says would
have immediately tipped them off to that
and been like well mr. negatives here
you know and so it really creates this
cool situation where spider-man just
kind of have to trust Eddie Brock now of
course Eddie Brock doesn't do anything
to benefit himself himself in this
situation he leaves Peter Parker tied up
to up whole and what used to be a meth
lab and then races off to try to find
Martin leak the funny thing this is why
this is why I love the spider-man comic
so much the way Dan Slott wrote him the
funny thing about this is that Peter
Parker's trying to make his escape right
like he has to grab acetone and he
basically kind of has to burn himself
you know as he's trying to get himself
out of his spider suit the problem is
that by the time he does by the time he
burns himself and gets himself out of
the suit antivenom shows up and puts the
put you know starts covering him in
webbing again so he's like really like I
just went through all this only to turn
around and be covered in this goo yet
again this is kind of it's that harder
luck it's just one of those inconvenient
moments I guess but from a year we pick
up with with with Carly Cooper because
again you know Carly Cooper is just kind
of watching all these events unfold
she's kind of you know trying to figure
out what's going on with regards to all
these sightings of the rake these rumors
that Jean dewolff is alive again this is
cool
because it gives us this other part of
the story that we wouldn't normally see
but what happens it's Carly Cooper you
know being a smartest year says look
ghosts don't have body heat they just
don't have body he that's not the way it
works and so when she's aren't wishes
witnessing the rate who is basically you
know kind of tormenting a guy for the
purpose of trying to trying to gain
information on what it is that mr.
negative is doing that Carly Cooper is
watching all the events unfold and she
says that's an actual person that's not
there's no way that's Jean dewolff
and if it is then how did she come back
from the dead and so it's just like
that's got to be somebody posing as you
know wolf I want to know who that person
is now following this whole
trail of what's going on with regards to
the right we kind of follow Carly Cooper
as she goes through this whole you know
process of trying to figure out what's
going on with Jean dewolff and that's
one of the reasons why this is kind of
cool is because it's like this little
intricate goody of a side story and with
regards to this whole lot that's all
darling and what we find out is carly
cooper goes to a place called the
special crimes evidence storage and what
this is is basically a location where
they store things you know like the
glider of green goblin bombs and you
know Mysterio's tech and so on and so
forth just super villains whose gears
and gadgets have been confiscated by the
police after their arrest the problem
with this is that currently cooper is
basically trolled by the officer on the
scene that evidence from that place
doesn't go missing instead that it was
destroyed there was a pumpkin bomb that
it went off and all the evidence was
completely obliterated but as Carly
Cooper's going through and looking at
all this she comes to the realization
that there was only one person who was
around that evidence room at the time of
the accident and that was Captain Yuri
Watanabe and so the idea here is that a
member of the police force in New York
is masquerading as the rate which is
actually kind of cool it's actually kind
of an interesting concept here some
wildly important it's not the most
important thing by any stretch of the
imagination it's just kind of
interesting but from here we switch back
to the Metropolitan Museum of Arts with
Peter Parker and antivenom of course
spending the time says hey look this is
where they're doing their whole mean
this is where they're doing their next
drug meeting you know I'm putting you
here out of sight because I want you to
see this I want you to see that Martin
Lee is mr. negative now the funny thing
about this is that mr. negative has a
Muramasa blade which is designed for the
purpose of disrupting people's healing
factors healing abilities and it
disrupts healing abilities regardless of
where those abilities come from because
remember when it comes to healing
factors in Marvel Comics whether it's
Wolverine Deadpool taken X 23 the
symbiote doesn't matter all the healing
happens on a cellular level and so what
the Muramasa blade us is it basically
just blocks people neo blocks their
cells from being able to regenerate and
so because of this you know with Martin
Lee showing up here you know with a
mystic blade attacking antivenom as long
as the blades in his body he's not going
to be able to heal from his attacks they
kick it all this is that wall Peter
Parker's being held here by anti-venom
well then suddenly we have great showing
up and that's kind of a funny thing is
Peter Parker you know Spiderman hadn't
really been investigating the whole race
thing didn't really even know it was
going on instead race is just here and
the whole idea is that he basically says
look lady like you're telling me you're
a ghost
that's fine I've met spirits of
vengeance alright I've met ghostwriter
I've seen people come back from the dead
I know what goes on I know the
difference you're not a ghost you're
using technology for Mysterio is what
you're doing and that's a funny thing
because the race is like on the roof
unscrew key you know she's being all
like this furious cloak and dagger he's
like yeah you're using Mysterio's tech
right and like a couple other gadgets so
stuff like that and the races is kind of
like uh yeah it's just a funny situation
because it's like the race is using all
the technology that Peter Parker's seen
before when you try was very soon so
that's nothing new to him you know it's
just kind of like that you're just using
stuff that I've seen before is just
somebody else doing it now of course the
allegiance the Alliance's is short-lived
I mean only insofar that it lasts long
enough for Peter Parker and races the
joining forces of antivenom and take out
you know mr. negative skies which they
you know for the most part succeed in
doing you know taking him out pretty
easily the issue with this is that of
course you know he ends up throwing his
death - you know a poison gas that will
basically take most people out but in
response to this of course you have your
partner who basically get the upper hand
and this major conflict and where mr.
negative seems to make his escape and he
seems to get away a race ends up using
the technology in her suit to basically
analyze the face of mr. negative to do a
side-by-side comparison with a 97%
accuracy match to verify that anti-venom
was telling the truth that mr. negative
is Martin Lee and so because of that
spider-man's basically was kind of
forced to trust it even though Michael I
guess he was right yeah I mean I guess
he was right when he said that like mr.
negative was Martin Lee and the result
is that he ends up going forward having
to not really trust Eddie Brock so to
speak but give him a little more
credence that he originally gave him in
addition to this the face of Martin Lee
and mr. negative just going to plaster
it all over the place I mean it's going
out to frontline and sent out to the
Daily Bugle it's put on the national
news the whole nine yards and so
everybody knows then Martin Lee and mr.
negative are the same person that
they're basically criminals and so
because of that it's more or less
everything that mr. negative has worked
for has essentially just come crashing
down around him and so because of that
you know where mr. negative makes his
escape you know where he's able to get
away this results in again this is kind
of mini alliance so to speak but it's
also carly cooper tracking down yuri
Watson Abhiyan saying why did you decide
to Don the mask of race why did you
decide to go on and beat us you know
vigilante character well of course
Watanabe says we were both Friends of
Jean dewolff we both know who she was
we were both friends of hers she was
shot in cold blood it was a senseless
I wanted to basically carry on the
mantle of the race I wanted people to
believe that she was back I wanted to
inspire fear in the hearts and minds of
individuals which is actually kind of a
cool concept but in the end it doesn't
really matter I mean it's kind of a cool
situation to see the way to return to a
degree but it doesn't have like any
major bearing on events that go on it's
really just kind of part of this mini
story in the background those are kind
of beef things up with it you know in
order to give it a little bit more than
just pay Peter Parker doesn't know if he
can trust anti-venom and now antivenoms
gonna prove him wrong you know it's just
kind of adding a little bit of
information but at the end of the day
things just kind of wind down with Peter
Parker talking to Carly Cooper and
that's no idea that he may reveal his
identity to her but instead he doesn't
you know where she keeps asking
questions where she keeps you know kind
of poking and prodding about his
relationship with spider-man he
basically offers you exactly an
explanation that he gave max Modell when
he's like well I'm not spider-man maybe
he says I basically just build
spider-man's gadgets for him and Carly
Cooper takes it as gospel truths but I
knew it I knew that you were somehow
involved with spider-man this is kind of
Dan Slott teasing that things may end up
becoming a little more interesting with
regards to the relationship between the
two but again at this point we don't
really know how that's going to flesh
out but we're not being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come and to explain
is you guys with the sub button to
become part of the Rob force if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like again it's just kind of a small
little filling stories really just kind
of a filler story to be honest kind of
bolster up the whole run of dance squad
a little bit it's by no means a wildly
important story just a fun little thing
they got thrown in here but yeah leave a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think then we'll catch you all
later please
[Music]